[Musique]
histoire de madame la pile
aujourd'hui 1er les peas abl
[Musique]
ja
or
m
et
ça y est
[Musique]
badini
m
là
hélas
[Musique]
dans une campagne verdoyante à l'orée
d'un bois au bord d'un petit ruisseau se
trouve belette ville nom d'une famille
de belette qui s'y installa il ya fort
longtemps belette ville s'étend tout au
long du petit ruisseau et s'enfonce dans
la forêt tout près de la forêt se trouve
la ferme dans la ferme habite le fermier
la fermière et leurs trois enfants
robin saisir et brume
elle m'a répondu
[Musique]
trop
aaaaah pc vous
[Musique]
au moins comme nam l'api vient elle
raconte des choses drôles
on sait tous avec elle tandis que vous
on a raison de dire que ton toujours
enfermés on devient bête en ce n'est pas
le cas des bateaux de la forêt thueux
sotoco rendent tout ce qu'il se croit
c'est pas parce qu'il était un bon cop
maintenant il est vieux et l'est se
concentraient ria pas dire c'était le
plus longtemps tenues plus on sonne
qui sait peut-être mais revient et on
travaille et va ouvrir un portail mais
ne soyez pas si glorieuse
[Musique]
la visite c'est la ferme d'en fermer
oui oui et on dirait aussi un nouveau
coq regarde clôture de quel bon mal
c'est pour remplacer note coq qui se
fait vieux
c'est pas comme son père qui reste à ce
niveau jusqu'à première communion de
robert auzelle coq au vin nous avons
mangé la au champignon
oui lardons
[Musique]
les flambées à la maniaque comment
t'appelles-tu d'où viens tu es mon est
ce vrai que c'est toi qui remplacera
notre code
le nouveau venu qui pour l'instant
tremblant son coin remplacera-t-il le
vieux coq
nous le saurons bientôt
et
[Musique]
il
le soleil
[Musique]
de santé
et
c
[Musique]
et
à
l'arrivée du nouveau coq bouleversa tous
le poulailler
tout le monde se demandait ce qui allait
arriver
les poules avec curiosité le vieux coq
avec en coin il n'y a pas à dire on
mangera du coq au vin à la ferme pour
toi n'y a pas fait que je sache je ne
sais pas si on mangera du coq au vin
il sera sûrement meilleur que la poule
au pot que vous deviendrez sous peu
[Musique]
e
comme le rêve de ma vie
mais vraiment je suis trop jeune l'heure
du dîner est en venu suzy la fille du
fermier apporte le grain aux poules en
compagnie de ses frères
robin et bruno il pénètre dans le
poulailler et admire le nouveau coq il
est presque aussi beau que le père de
notre vieux coq
moi je crois qu'il est plus beau une le
plus beau le plus beau une est aussi
beau toujours sûrs de parole d'exxon
le soir tombe
[Musique]
lendemain matin john autre vieux coq
toujours levé le premier attend que son
successeur s'éveille pour annoncer leur
or ils ne bougent pas quelques mailles
c'est beau la jeunesse mais le travail
ce travail
cocorico
dans la forêt proche tout vit déjà les
oiseaux l'api le coucou la tribu des
belettes
et le petit 1 qui dans cet échange
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
frattini
adieu
et
mais qu'il faut mais qui vont passer le
renard
heureusement vous êtes là comme maire
heureusement s'il n'était pas là vous
aviez tous mangé un espace corbeau
allons ne vous battez pas le renard est
toujours en femme et il faut donc s'en
méfier
et si madame l'api ne surveillait pas
tous qui vous préviendrai coucou coucou
cela m'est égal le renard n'aime pas les
cocos coucou que tu dis madame l'api ne
parlait pas grossièrement haut
[Musique]
je sors le soleil
genre
de santé
et
[Musique]
m
y aller
et
[Musique]
nous voici revenu au poulailler où tout
est changé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le jeune coq a pris de l'assurance et se
pavane au milieu des poules admirative
[Musique]
le vieux coq délaissé est tout triste
dans un coin et la contraire bonjour
madame pic me voulez vous vous en faites
une tête il ya de quoi
regardez comment me trade
et pourtant c'est moi qui fais tout ici
l'ordre la discipline c'est moi qui
réveille la ferme
le nouveau lui se lève un quart d'heure
après tout le monde et si on attendait
après lui pour réveiller le fermier
quelle famille si dur mais on pourrait
toujours à temps plein alors dit calme
ce matin on a entendu le fermier et dire
que les cousins est arrivé c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle non plus tôt et
pourtant vous étiez si fier d'être un
jour kakovin comme votre père t'a
glorieux sort non oui c'est un glorieux
sort quand il est très lointain même moi
je me sens si genou co alors que faire
fumer est bien c'est une idée venez avec
moi dans la forêt
[Musique]
ce bruit qui fait fuir madame puces et
suzy qui apporte du grain en poule mais
elle a perdu quelque chose mon bracelet
[Musique]
mais le fermier très en colère alors
oula tu perds du temps bracelet aussi
beau bracelet en or parce qu'au nord
c'est pas malheureux pendant que le
fermier grands de sa fille rebelle bruno
rentrer deschamps
notre vieux coq qui surveille de la mare
aux canards ce qui se passe se cache
vite guettant la première occasion de
s'enfuir dans la forme et le fermier
crie toujours alors c'est qu'on a volé
il faut savoir qui
[Musique]
g
ce soleil
[Musique]
peut-être
et
c'est tout
[Musique]
et
là
nous en sommes restés au moment où robin
et bruno rentrant deschamps ouvrez la
barrière effrayés par les cris de suzy
il se précipite dans la cour oubliant de
refermer
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
bon alors si ces personnes de chez nous
selon l'api dit le fermier très en
colère mais papa merle qui prenait l'air
sur une branche de l'arbre bord dans le
poulailler l'a entendu
et c'est ainsi que négus le corbeau l'a
pris
madame pipi madame pitt
le bracelet de la petite suzy de la
ferme a disparu le fermier vous accuse
et il dit comment accuser mois moi qui
suis innocente je n'ai jamais vu ce
bracelet il m'est arrivé enfin il
pouvait m'arriver le prendre au mot sans
le vouloir des petites choses mais un
bracelet au fait qu'elle est et comment
ce bracelet en or alors un bracelet au
nord je m'étouffe jamais une chose
pareille mais d'arriver au nord
et c'est moi qu'on accuse mois une
innocente au secours au secours
[Musique]
oh
pendant qu'à la ferme toute la famille
du fermier continue ses recherches les
plus fébriles
le vieux cas que lui kurd tout la
vitesse de ses pattes
il atteint la forêt
ouf
jamais de ma vie je n'ai couru
pareillement tiens je ne savais même pas
que j'en étais capable
mac and a whole home à cannes
francky tour a beau ne ferme plus à lui
tel fristot son bar du refus ce taux
passe de grimper d'un si beau si beau
mais changer un bon âge quelle triste
sort que le triste sort est devenu un
coq au vin pour tous les jeunes locaux
quelle triste au sort quelle triste
[Musique]
il faisait jour encore la route est
belle et comme il est agréable d'être
libre et de cheminée sans contrainte
[Musique]
parent
or y a pas à dire la liberté lax
aux coups que cet animal qui m'a frôlé
annoncer rien c'est une feuille morte
wow quelle peur je n'ai pas l'habitude
d'être seul et sur une route déserte et
certainement plein de dangers
mais la liberté ça s'apprend et
j'apprendrai allons mon vieux jo soit
brave ton père était un grand et beau
coq et il était brave ton grand père
était un très très beau coq il était
brave ton arrière grand père mais au
fait comment était-il l'arrière grand
papa où nous en sommes il devait être
très très braves alors soit digne d'une
aussi grande lignée et en avant hier
redresse en la crête geôles coque
s'enfonce à l'accord
[Musique]
nous voici dans la cour de la ferme ou
blanche est la petite poule vient de
trouver quelque chose qui brille
[Musique]
pendant ce temps dans la forêt le coq
marche de plus en plus lentement
[Musique]
en huit ans
oh
e
moi
[Musique]
oh
je suis fatigué
quelle aventure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il dont pourquoi tout ce
bruit
tu es tu je suis le coq de la ferme qui
est près de belette ville
tiens c'est la première fois que je vois
un coq et pourtant j'ai entendu parler
de toi par madame pillent évidemment moi
aussi c'est la première fois que je vois
une chouette je n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de sortir de la ferme
si je suis parti c'est parce que le
fermier vient d'acheter un jeune coq on
le regardait tout le temps on parlait
trop de mon père cela a fini par me
mettre la puce à la crête
je me sens danger or comme je te
comprends c'est incroyable comme les
hommes sont ingrats quand leurs vieux
serviteur ne peuvent plus les servir
ils les mangent enfin ceci n'est pas une
raison pour réveiller les chouettes à
des heures pareil de toute façon un
conseil ne jamais passer la nuit sous un
arbre à cause du renard et demander
asile un animal compréhensifs
oh oui madame la chouette
merci beaucoup le chemin devient de plus
en plus étroits
il fait encore sombre
de temps en temps une petite clairière
apparaît entre deux énormes chaîne
le jour se lève
la forêt s'éveille voyons voyons voyons
commençons par ainsi dans notre famille
le champ commence toujours par un si vif
ici qui chante faux si office est pas
possible tu le fais exprès fifi ne
comprend décidément rien à la musique
que papa merle se donne tant de mal à
lui apprendre
celui ci use de son parapluie mais
l'émotion fait oublier à fifi il est un
merlot bien élevé et c'est inadmissible
jo est très fâché ces jeunes
quel manque d'éducation
c'est à peine croyable mais à quoi bon
penser avec cette belle journée qui
s'annonce et la forêt est jours le cac
par découvrir la forêt
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
que veux tu j'ai faim et bien cherché
des vers de terre
non je n'aime pas les vers de terre j'en
mange de temps en temps pour mes quatre
heures mais je préfère une bouillie
tiens voilà de la soupe et un peu d'eau
fraîche
merci merci tu es gentil pour être
gentil il est gentil mais vraiment l'ena
ont peu d'appétit c'est pas comme moi à
la ferme c'est moi à qui
enfin me remet non pas des souvenirs
inutile
[Musique]
testard go qui se promet que fais-tu si
loin et on poulailler tu sais où
j'habite
mais je te connais fort bien je roule
très souvent autour d'un ferme pour voir
si je trouve des oeufs
comment les oeufs de mes poules on ne
peut ce qu'il y'a personne ce n'est pas
une fréquentation pour moi c'est affreux
ma crainte est si sensible que le voyou
qui a osé aux sétois l'écureuil tu n'as
pas honte de te moquer d'un vieux coq
fatiguée et affamée à les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui n'ont aucune éducation eau
excuse moi mais tu fais tu si loin de ta
ferme
c'est la première fois que je vois un
coq dans les parages et oui mais que
veux tu je fuis ma ferme on me trouve
trop vieux et on veut manger
et pourtant
tu savais bien chez moi
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle nono je suis encore
célibataire tu es chez toi mange et
repose toi non
la fermière appelle ainsi son petit
bruno le plus jeune de ses fils celui
qui est si mignon
oui mais moi ces nounous l'écureuil n'y
pense plus apte à faire dans la forêt on
y libre et tu seras heureux oh le pauvre
au jeu les chercher un bel épis de blé
ça lui fera plaisir
madame pipi de l'amupi le coq de la
ferme et retrouvée ce vieux jeu vous
pour que le farceur ce matin le merle
m'a dit qu'ils n'étaient plus employées
et je croyais qu'il était en train de
cuire propos euros
croyez-vous chère madame douce
cache-t-il
chez nono l'écureuil ils se
connaissaient dont je n'en sais rien
mais ils se connaissent maintenant
bon ce n'est pas tout il faut que
j'aille le chercher son épi de blé
à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et croyez nous
m
[Musique]
c'est là
je vais mieux
il n'y a rien de tel qu'une bonne année
et un pouls des jeunes et pour vous
remettre
[Musique]
coucou coup je suis le coucou avec nous
tu es sedan sécurité coucou coucou vient
la maison il ya bon dîner au que vous
êtes gentils mes amis que cela me fait
du bien
[Musique]
[Rires]
thieux fallou blanchette vita on dirait
qu'elle a trouvé quelque chose et puis
quand as-tu ce bracelet ont été trouvés
cachottière jeudi la perte il est ce moi
qui me touchent les jolis mots
[Musique]
la pauvre madame pic on accuse n'allais
pas me lancer
non non on n'a rien vu
la politique de non intervention au cher
que vous êtes savons tous que vous
parlez bien
parfaitement nous sommes pour la
non-intervention passe-t-il il règne une
excitation anormal par ici il faut voir
ça de près mais c'est le bracelet de
suzy oro au me faire ça à moi me laisser
accusé d'un vol dont le saviez innocente
on le savait rien on vient de
l'apprendre
vous êtes de vilaines man 2 ou le saviez
fort bien mais ça ne va pas se passer
comme ça et toi sale petite gamine
les six accusés une honorable mère de
famille à ta place
moi qui n'ai jamais rien pris enfin très
rarement vilaine vilaine petite volaille
et madame l'api jure de se venger
mais avant tout il faut rendre le
bracelet et en montrant bien que c'est
elle madame l'api injustement accusés
qui l'a retrouvé mais comment s'y
prendre
elle plonge vers blanchatte se venge
saisi le bracelet s'envole hésite un
moment et le laisse tomber devant la
porte du fermier puis elle attend nous
aussi mes petits amis
nous allons attendre le prochain épisode
pour la suite des événements
[Musique]
jean
m
c'est tout
d
radi
[Musique]
et
nous avons quitté madame l'api au moment
où toute fière d'avoir retrouvé le
bracelet de la petite suzy elle laissait
tomber devant la porte du fermier et ce
qu'elle avait prévu arrive le fermier
ouvre sa porte et voit le bracelet
il reste un moment stupéfait et se met à
crier parce que je vois donc qu'est ce
que ça veut dire un bracelet disparaît
il vient tout seul bah non
bon on se moque de qui ici je vais vous
dressez moi je suis trop gentil trop bon
père ah bah ça va pas se passer comme ça
mais la petite fusée est ravi d'avoir
retrouvé son joli bracelet chic membres
ainsi que je suis contente
[Musique]
les madame l'api joyeuse et fier de sa
bonne action sautille de contentement
sur sa branche
cependant elle s'aperçoit que le fermier
la regardent d'un oeil soupçonneux
[Musique]
quelques regards fillon vite
la voilà la reconnaissance des hommes
s'étaient hissés vers et soupçonneux
encore un peu il m'aurait accusé au on
ne sait jamais il s'en tiendra
et dire que c'est moi qui rapportait le
bracelet est bine soyez honnête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et dès le lendemain madame l'api raconte
à tous à tout le monde et à sa façon
[Musique]
alors je vis le bracelet le petit suzy
c'était ces vilaines poule qui l'avait
pris évidemment cette petite soeur de
blanchette que je n'avais jamais
remarqué une si petite
une gamine quoi et bien c'est elle c'est
elle qui joue un les plus bracelet à qui
se fier grand dieu mais c'est à peine
croyable et le fermier et les enfants il
était content je pense
le fermier c'était incroyable je ne l'aï
jamais vu aussi ému il ne cessait de
répéter merci madame pays merci madame
pipe sans vous que serions nous devenus
ce vrai en quel brave homme ce fermier
au fond sous ses airs bourrus c'est un
grand coeur oui pour un grand coeur
c'est un grand coeur c'est dommage
qu'ils ne montrent pas assez
enfin moi je suis contente tout le
poulailler c'est que je suis innocente
[Musique]
et maintenant toute la forêt elle sait
aussi ce n'est que justice
[Musique]
e
cocorico
[Musique]
d
c
[Musique]
le soleil
sow
santé
et
[Musique]
je ne
m
dallas
et
non
[Musique]
l'api ayant retrouvé le corps cachés
dans la forêt chez nono l'écureuil tous
deux parlent de la ferme et se
souviennent et vous vous souvenez madame
l'appui de la colère dit fermiers
proposent chacune a pu être drôle
[Musique]
oui à la papa parce qu'il a pu être
drôle
ce matin le cas alors à non ce matin il
m'a regardé d'un drôle d'air dallaire
qui m'accusaient or les hommes et au
bouillon enfin ici les oiseaux sont très
gentils et je suis très heureux si
heureux que ça mais oui si heureux que
ça croyez vous que je regrette la ferme
et ses fermiers incapable de m'apprécier
et qui veulent me manger patients
incapables que ça que voulez vous dire
et bien ce matin le fermier a dit où est
il donc notre vieux coq c'était un bon
et fidèle serviteur il a dit ça coco ho
ho ho ho ho ho que je suis content il a
vraiment dit ça parce que vous savez
allons allons compères cessé de jouer la
comédie
vous savez bien que vous ne demandez que
ça que quoi rentrer à la ferme bas
peut-être que oui peut-être que non ça
dépend
c'est tout redevient comme avant si je
n'entends plus parler de coq au vin
alors cessez donc de re goûter vous
mourrez d'envié de revenir à la ferme
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs votre fille aînée est en
train de couver vous allez être
grand-père gropper noah modem l'api
bien sûr que je veux rentrer à la ferme
le devoir m'appelle ma fille a besoin de
moi je n'hésite plus je rentrerai demain
pourquoi pas maintenant parce que nono
l'écureuil donne une fête en mon honneur
tous mes amis sont alités
vous êtes aussi invités merci j'accepte
mais demain soyez tranquilles madame pis
quand le devoir m'appelle je n'hésite
jamais
venus tous voir les préparatifs de la
fête c'est magnifique
le soleil est là
elle appelle à la note
[Musique]
non
je ne
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
nous nous sommes quittés au moment où le
jeune coq en retard comme toujours
lancer un cocorico timide malgré sa
timidité le cocorico réveilla le fermier
qui regarde à l'heure et d'émotions
failli tomber de son livre comment notre
coq chante avec près de 20 minutes de
retard
ah bah alors ça coco alors ça on peut
voir confiance et le fermier sort de
chez lui forte en colère il se dirige
vers le poulailler
[Musique]
un à un
dame d'amour est il le vieux coq beau
suis là au moins il était un bon et
fidèle serviteur il savait maintenir
l'ordre dans le poulailler
mais où et qui dont alors personne ne
sait ce qui se passe chez moi au seul la
petite saisies aux répondre mais papa on
ne l'a plus revu depuis longtemps tiens
depuis que mon bracelet a disparu
étrange étrange
[Musique]
et
à
le fermier à l'âme et du taux pour
s'apercevoir que joe avait disparu c'est
pas comme nous nous on avait tout de
suite
au fait on devrait demander à madame
fille je suis sûr qu'elle a des
nouvelles
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont ces poules à
caqueter comme ça elles sont trop
excités et aussi trop nombreuses
tiens donc on va c'était le bracelet on
a une bonne poule au pot robin et romain
attrape la plus grosse celle qui crie le
plus fort ta mère va la préparer pour le
dîner quand deux mois voilà ce que c'est
que de crier toujours te faire remarquer
il faut jouer comme tout cela jo il ne
sait rien le pauvre
[Musique]
et madame l'api que faites vous là
comment saviez-vous jetait le voyons une
jauge c'est tout moi le matin
j'entrouvre ma porte et j'écoute les
nouvelles et quelles sont les dernières
nouvelles et à la ferme
que se passe-t-il donc on a retrouvé le
bracelet non c'est impossible
chers petits bracelets dire que c'est à
cause de lui que j'ai pu m'enfuir et
qu'il a pris je me suis souvent demandé
y que donneriez-vous pour le savoir rien
je n'ai rien même plus ma canne et bien
c'est cette petite synthe de blanchette
aux adorables petites blanche est l
histoire et la colère du fermier
[Musique]
le soleil
genre
[Musique]
de santé
et
ça y est
c'est
m
[Musique]
pratique
et
hélas
[Musique]
le soleil
ça
[Musique]
je souhaite
m
[Musique]
pratique
et
apa
non
[Musique]
toute la forêt donne une réception en
l'honneur de john cac
madame la fille et la hongrie wallet jo
ayant déclaré que c'était le plus beau
jour de sa vie
le festin classes et les petits nains ou
à la chanteuse le soleil du matin
radieux
chantôme le soleil brille il variera
mieux chômage
chantons la douceur de la vie d' alerte
le renard
[Musique]
pourquoi alerte ces gentilles est
revenue à ma réception à ça près de
gentil c'est très gentil mais avant de
discuter monde sur la branche mais tout
le monde l'a fui ils sont tous au delà
arbres c'est de discuter
quel sale habitude montée je
t'expliquerai philippe et les éléments
de pointe
le jeune peut plonger trop manger et
puis j'oserais vous avouer que voler
n'est pas mon fort
je suis un oiseau terrestre une cale
entêté et vous autres là haut il
s'essaie trois autres terrestre au
secours ne me brutaliser pas j'ai peur
j'ai le mal de l'air
or je n'ai jamais pu supporter
l'altitude bas par une fois de la
supportera l'altitude mode homme là pis
il me semble que vous me tutoyez part
d'éléments à jo c'est l'émotion je vous
pardonne mais je ne veux pas redonne pas
mon ascension au j'ai le vertige comme
je voulais dit l'altitude ne me vaut
rien je veux descendre jamais pour que
le renard vous mange
d'autant qu'il adore les poules je vous
ferai remarquer que je ne suis pas une
poule
disons que pour le renard vous êtes
d'une grosse poule
il l'a hélas hélas ne tombait pas de la
branche voilà la plus grande injure que
l'on puisse me faire à cette position en
commun des temps plus indignes de ma
personne je veux redescendre tient le
renard doit être partie les petits
nation revenus
[Musique]
non on descend ou non bon tu es prêt oui
mais doucement doucement doucement je le
vertige
ouf le volant sécurité sécurité
parlons-en à la ferme j'étais destiné à
la casserole et l'eau la forêt où je me
croyais enfin tranquille je suis une
grosse poule pour le renard mourir pour
mourir
je préfère une mort glorieuse clore en
route
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sous le soleil
il
[Musique]
sow
oh
c
en acceptant de rentrer à la ferme
jo le coq suis madame l'api tu lui
montre le chemin en sautillant de
branche en branche
il reprend en sens inverse le chemin qui
mène à la ferme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame pays c'est bientôt la ferme
etes-vous toujours bien sûr de ce que
vous avancez on me regrette bien là bas
je ne vais pas aller à la casserole
écoutez jo je vous en prie ne vous
répétez pas tout le temps c'est fatigant
inutile
tout le monde sait que les vieilles
personnes radote mais à ce point là
vieille personne vieilles personnes
je vous en prie madame pitt je suis
encore jeune
et puis je vous préviens que la barrière
de la ferme et en terme et une pourront
jamais entrer mais si je connais un
passage secret mais ce merveilleux vous
savez tout ainsi quand je voudrais faire
une petite escapade dans la forêt je
n'aurai qu'à passer par là qu'il revient
appel et le voilà qui pensent déjà aux
escapades
eh bien la voilà votre ferme oh quelle
drôle d'effet au tout est comme avant il
me semble n'être jamais parti en effet
rien n'a changé à la ferme saisie porte
leur gras aux poules et les canards
viennent de la mare pour manger leur
patrie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme chacun est très occupé par son
dîner personne ne remarque joe qui tout
naturellement reprend sa place et se
mettent à picorer dans la cour la petite
fusée la perçoit
[Musique]
notre vieux joe notre vieux jo il est
revenu à ses mots tout le monde à court
mais oui c'est incroyable quand aux
fermiers ils ne changent pas d'idée
bien sûr comme il n'a jamais bougé d'ici
aussi on compter sur vous pour regarder
quelque chose à oger bien assez à faire
comme ça le poulailler c'est votre
affaire d'amour
[Musique]
tiens tiens on s'ennuyait de nous tous
savoir où tu étais qui nous manquait
beaucoup
taisez vous et ne me posais pas de
questions
à partir d'aujourd'hui l'ordre va régner
dans le poulailler et la grosse
jacquotte la grosse jacob qu'est-elle
devenue
l'ine poule au pot voilà ce qui arrive
quand on est trop bavarde été bonne au
moins aucun écho n'est parvenue jusqu'à
nous personnels en a parlé
donc même en poule au pot elle n'était
pas réussi ça ne m'étonne pas avec son
mauvais caractère
[Musique]
le lendemain matin
le coq chante à l'est et le fermier se
réveilla tu
ou offre est réveilla le ca change toute
la journée c'est ça l'ordre et un peu
plus tard au petit déjeuner en famille
le fermier déclara qu'il était très
satisfait et qu'il leur pardonnait tout
ne va pas on n'a rien fait ça ne fait
rien je vous pardonne quand même et dans
la joie générale la vie à la ferme
recommence à corps
[Musique]
savez vous ma chère que j'ai entendu la
fermière dit comme les enfants iront à
l'école et moi figurez-vous que l'autre
jour j'ai entendu ceci à l'on commet
toujours aussi bavarde est aussi
malveillante dans la forêt j'ai oublié
combien c'était fatigant de vous
entendre
taisez vous je veux une tranquillité
absolue compris which you with you et
l'autre coque et il ne fait rien
[Musique]
vous
je suis là jo je m'appelle hubert bon
hubert tu te tiens dans l'autre coin et
tu tâche de faire respecter l'ordre vue
[Musique]
oui jo compris c'est un jeudi cac vous
en mouvement de rien 1
c'est à lui que je m'adresse comment
déjà hubert pour te servir jo bon film
maintenant
[Musique]
avez vous été sage
bon alors grand papa va vous raconter
une belle histoire une très belle
histoire
voyez-vous mais petit j'étais en grand
danger
oui alors prenons tout mon courage je
suis partie de la ferme
oui j'ai traversé la forêt j'ai traversé
la forêt visage je me suis fait des amis
avec eux j'ai combattu le renard
évidemment le renard fait vaincue et me
voilà de retour
voyez-vous mes petits quand on a des
amis des vrais amis tout est possible
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]